beans beans magical fruit the more you
eat the more you
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's vlog is sponsored by foddy
and i'm gonna be taking you with me
through my very long
low fodmap elimination diet and trial
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor foddy foods
so foddy was a game changer for me
in this process as a super busy person
now with two kids and a business to run
i was
really honestly quite anxious about
starting this whole low fodmap trial
because i knew how much from scratch
cooking
i would probably have to do like onions
and garlic
are two of the main sources of fodmaps
that i would have to eliminate in the
first
phase and onion and garlic are in
everything
so i don't honestly always have time to
make every
single sauce and seasoning from scratch
so i was really worried about having to
eat
basically everything super boring and
super bland
but foddy has a wide range of products
that make eating low fodmap
so much easier and more enjoyable and
that allows people with food
sensitivities to say yes
to flavors that they already love so
they have salsa
sauces dressings spice seasoning mixes
and oils all of which are certified low
fodmap by the monash
institute i honestly love their pasta
sauce probably even more
than my homemade version so kudos to
them
for that major win so if you're
suffering from digestive issues
bloating or are considering trialling a
low fodmap diet
say yes with foddy foods and visit the
link in the description and use my promo
code abby15
for 15 off also you can pause my screen
to read my disclaimer
but i do want a flag that i do not i
repeat
do not recommend that everybody eat a
low fodmap diet without speaking to your
doctor and dietitian
this is a therapeutic diet process which
should be
carefully monitored and structured by a
professional
and it's not meant to be a lifelong diet
this video may also be triggering to
those with histories of restrictive
eating
so feel free to skip this if it's not
supportive to your journey
so i want to start by very quickly
explaining what the heck
a low fodmap elimination trial is and
why you shouldn't all
race out start this as a weight loss fad
so fodmap stands for fermentable
oligo dye monosaccharides and polyols
so these are short chain carbohydrates
that are poorly digested
so they often sit and ferment in the
intestine
where they can cause gas diarrhea cramps
and bloating
since giving birth i've been dealing
with really severe
gas distension and painful bloating and
it just seems like it's been getting
worse
since i did my first video on the topic
which you can watch
right here so after the holidays i
decided
that if there was ever a time to do an
elimination diet
it would probably be easiest when we're
in lockdown
in you know cover times and i'm not
being invited out
every single weekend for dinner with
friends so i hired my colleague ali
coogler who
specializes in digestive nutrition and
she helped me
safely go through a three-step protocol
with her motivation and support
also i think it's really strange that
when i mentioned that i had an
rd on my instagram post so many of you
said that it was like so meta that a
dietitian would need to see a dietitian
but honestly why not like therapists
see therapists and professional athletes
have
athlete coaches we all need mentorship
and support to grow and to see the
bigger picture
but i think this serves as a really good
reminder to all of you
that even if you think you know what
you're doing with this diet
it's actually very complicated intense
and requires a lot of dedication and
work
and therefore i do strongly urge getting
professional assistance to ensure that
you're not
unnecessarily restricting and also still
meeting your nutrient needs
okay so back to fodmaps there are
different
classes or categories of fodmaps each of
which have a variety of major food
sources
so the common fodmaps include fructose
which is found in foods like honey
asparagus pears ripe banana and apples
lactose found in dairy products like
milk cheese and ice cream
fructans which are found in foods like
garlic onions
cabbage and also in grains like wheat
galacto oligosaccharides aka galactins
which are found in legumes and soy
products
and then polyols which are found in a
ton of fruit and veg
like blackberries cauliflower mushrooms
plums
and also in sugar alcohol sweeteners
like mannitol
and sorbitol i did a lot of symptom
tracking myself in the many weeks
leading up to my first meeting with ali
so i had already kind of narrowed down
the most likely culprits
to be vegetables beans and
possibly some fruit so because i just
knew i honestly did not have the
bandwidth to take on more than i needed
to
and also i didn't want any extreme
restriction to trigger me
in any way based on my history with
orthorexia
i opted to do a modified low fodmap
elimination
what i kind of call low fodmap light so
in other words for me i decided that i
wasn't going to fuss too much about
having some wheat or dairy in my diet
and i was going to focus on what i was
more confident
was causing the issues honestly i'm
running on like four hours of nightly
sleep trying to work with two kids
during legit pandemic
it would probably have been a slippery
slope for me
and my mental health if i had to give up
ice cream
and regular pasta in addition to some of
my
go-to staple vegetables i also want to
make it super clear
that the low fodmap diet is kind of a
misnomer
because you're not supposed to do phase
one for your life
this should also not be used as a weight
loss diet
i know that i've heard of a lot of folks
using the rigidity of the low fodmap
diet to kind of
mask or disguise disordered eating or to
justify extreme
caloric restriction so this is why i
really do urge you to approach this
with professional supervision and also
with the mindset
that this is just a temporary test
i repeat it's a test not a long-term
diet the goal here is to get to the
other side with a very clear indication
of exactly
which foods cause you trouble and
exactly
how much you can tolerate so that
hopefully
you don't need to actually eliminate
much in the long run
okay so how does this work phase one
the elimination this involves eating
only low fodmap foods
or moderate fodmap foods in the
quantities that render them
essentially low fodmap the first phase
here generally takes around two to six
weeks to get complete resolution of your
symptoms
before you can move on to phase two now
if i were to give you any suggestions
based on my experience
it would be to do your grocery shopping
after you have your plan in place
because i ended up with a lot of things
in my fridge that
i wasn't supposed to eat i'm annoyed i
didn't think about this before i got my
groceries today but
cashew milk is high fodmap and soy milk
is high thought map
so probably should have bought almond
milk this week
i guess i'm going shopping again and i
did which also meant i need to do a
proper
taste test of three different almond
milks to determine the best one
for my ritualistic morning latte
honestly i already felt like i was
giving up so
much so i wanted to make sure that my
coffee
still was an enjoyable part of my day
even if it meant spending
a little bit more on non-dairy milk that
week
approved
that's a 10. so yeah
the first few days were really hard
because i had a lot of high fodmap foods
still in the fridge that i am kind of
just used to
basically popping in my mouth whenever i
want so it was definitely
an exercise in more mindful eating
reason number 529 why this is a
challenge for me
as i'm like cleaning up my kids dinner
plate and like putting his scraps into
the garbage like it's just my inherent
instinct to just like pop random pieces
of
his leftovers in my mouth a lot of wish
were probably
not low fodmap so i need to be a lot
more mindful
about that probably in general but i
think that's something that a lot of
moms probably do i also felt like
telling myself
not to eat something was just a setup
for making me
want it even more obviously classic
diet mentality right here like suffer
with vegetables
um i know i'm not supposed to have a lot
of broccoli right now and i have this
cooked
delicious looking broccoli that i made
for my son
staring at me and i just want to eat it
so badly but to do this properly without
feeling deprived
i knew that i had to dedicate extra time
to home cooking
and food prep so i put all the low
fodmap veggies on my shopping list
and i got chopping so bell pepper and
cucumber
not my favorite vegetables of all time
but they are low fodmap
so i did purchase a bunch and i'm gonna
chop them up and get them ready for just
like grab-and-go options
um and that way i'm not like just kind
of mindlessly reaching for
a piece of like broccoli or cauliflower
or something else that's being prepared
in the fridge for my son
i've got some options that are ready to
go and also a little bit easier on the
gut for me
i gotta say bell peppers used to not be
my favorite but they're growing on me
i just wish i had some hummus pretty
different
but i wouldn't go so well my dietitian
and i agreed to limit my raw veggie and
salad intake to
no more than one raw veggie dish a day
made obviously with low fodmap veggies
so
i would be eating basically most of my
vegetables
cooked and that meant a lot of meal prep
[Music]
we did fennel today folks roasted
fennel
with balsamic and olive oil so good i
totally forgot i actually liked fennel i
forgot all about fennel
so this is actually good it's actually
kind of reintroducing me to
some long-lost veggies and fruit that
maybe i kind of forgotten about
so this is kind of a good thing
[Music]
worth worth the loss of potential
taste buds i also had to eliminate
legumes which
are a huge staple in my diet so that did
mean relying on
more animal protein during these weeks
which
i just kind of had to be okay with extra
firm tofu
is low fodmap so i did eat a lot of that
but basically most other plant-based
sources of protein are not
so i definitely would imagine that this
phase of the diet would be
extra challenging for some of my
plant-based friends i
also relied a lot on my fatty products
for adding flavor
without having to make everything from
scratch so
many prepared sauces and dips and
seasonings contain
onions and garlic and other fodmaps i
mean like
everything has onion and garlic in it so
it was a huge relief to be able to have
some ready-made options and snacks
that i could just rely on to get me
through this first elimination phase
i also knew that i couldn't go months
without ordering some takeout in
so i found basically the lowest possible
fodmap options during those weeks
and i gave myself the flexibility and
the grace to do just that
in some cases it would mean going for
some of the less healthy
takeout options but honestly it really
did not matter
at all to me as i totally just needed
some relief from
the monotony of roasted low-fodmap veg
just saying but alas i survived and for
the most part
i tried to make meals that were both
saturating and satisfying so that i
didn't feel deprived
here are some of the things that i ate
[Music]
but i also had some hard days where
honestly i just kind of wanted to go eat
a tub of hummus
and totally give up and i think that was
a really good reminder to me
as a healthcare professional just how
challenging
some of these major diet changes can be
for people
and how much empathy we need to have as
clinicians for those who take them on
so i'm having a bit of a rough day today
i don't know what it is if it's just
you know oh was up really early this
morning and i didn't sleep well
and you know i just feel so exhausted
and overwhelmed trying to do
so much meal prep like honestly i it's
like all i do is
cook vegetables and i just i don't know
i just feel like
i'm worried that i'm gonna have to do
this for the rest of my life or choose
between being comfortable
and being overwhelmed so yeah and
i mean if i'm struggling with this i
can't imagine how everyone else feels
who
you know don't have the nutrition
knowledge base that i have not to
mention i'm not even doing this full out
i'm doing like a low
fodmap like a mini low fodmap yeah i i
have so much empathy for anyone who's
dealing with digestive issues and
attempting to balance motherhood or
parenthood
and work and this very restrictive
elimination phase it's rough so i'm
literally counting down the hours until
my next appointment with my dietitian so
that i can
hopefully get to the bottom of what i
can
ease up on a little bit so maybe to make
it a little bit easier for me
but i will say that the silver lining
was that i was reminded
of my love for some fruits and
vegetables that i had totally neglected
or
basically forgotten about over the years
i used to really hate cantaloupe
i saw it as like the runt of the fruit
salad that nobody wanted
the filler you know and it is a filler
like they they
people at restaurants like restaurants
always pack their fruit salads full of
cantaloupe and honeydew melon because
it's cheap
and then they don't have to give you as
many the good things like berries but
i'm starting to appreciate
the old cantaloupe it's sweet and it's
juicy and it's
cold and refreshing and it's low fodmap
i have a new i have a new love all right
let's talk about what i learned
in phase two number one i do not really
like
cooked bell peppers hard pass for me
i also don't love eggplant at all
unless i would say it's like breaded
pan fried and loaded with cheese so
two i am obsessed with parsnips and
carrots i guess
i totally forgot about parsnips somehow
and i've been eating an exorbitant
amount of carrots because it's probably
one of the only low fodmap vegetables
that i actually really like
so much so that my hands are even more
orange than normal
and no there's nothing wrong with me
this is just like a genetic situation
and it's totally benign it's nothing
that you need to worry about
three i desperately miss
broccoli and cauliflower and brussels
sprouts and cabbage and all those
sulfurous vegetables
which i know is such a geeky dietitian
thing to be even
talking about because it's like not even
it's not that i miss
ice cream and and bread i miss
vegetables specifically vegetables that
stink
um so yeah oh i do miss a good brussels
sprout
four yeah the big one is really that i
think
like before if my symptoms were like an
eight or nine
now there may be more like a four or
five which is
significant that's a significant
improvement
but i know like at the start of this i
guess i had some pretty lofty
expectations just based on everything
that people had said to me and that
you know i've had so many so many
people's success stories saying that
oh you know they completely got rid of
all of their symptoms and
and you know they're bloating they lost
five inches in
like two weeks because of all the
bloating that just magically went away
not a fart in the world and stuff so
it's like
yeah that has not been my experience
first of all i never really cared about
the kind of bloating situation and the
aesthetics of it but i definitely still
have significant pain
and some discomfort and gas and things
like that so it's not like all
you know all my symptoms are gone and it
really comes down to
how rushed and stressed and exhausted
um i am feeling at that time of the meal
i think that's really what
determines how it's gonna go i'm kind of
disappointed that it's probably all
you know this is as good as it's gonna
get but you know i guess it's better
than it was so let's move on to stage
two next is phase two the reintroduction
so this phase can take a while usually
two to three months or so
and again i did a bit of an abbreviated
version because
i can't spend six months of my already
overflowing life
thinking about every single food i pop
in my mouth
but essentially ali had me introduce a
few
different foods from each fodmap
category and introduce them
over three days in gradually increasing
serving sizes this way we could catch
when symptoms
started to kind of flare up so that we
would know exactly
which foods and how much were an issue
for me so i went through the list of
foods we agreed on and made very
detailed notes on how each of them
made me feel now i have to say it was a
huge relief to be able to have a little
bit more flexibility in my diet
you know adding in small quantities of
the foods that i hadn't had in a while
felt so glorious and truly freeing
like pear for example is kind in season
right now and it was
so nice to have a little bit with my
breakfast
and cabbage like i missed cabbage
so yeah the reintroduction phase was
strangely fun
so today is the last day of my
cauliflower trial
and i have to tell you i am so nervous
because i love cauliflower and i'm just
gonna be like really
disappointed and sad to feel like i need
to
give it up or like at least be cautious
about it i know this is the whole point
of doing
a low fodmap trial here is to get to the
bottom of the exact foods that cause
some digestive issues but i'm just not
ready to feel
like this is the one i know that's so
sad
it could be worse it could be ice cream
it could it could be chocolate
it could be coffee it could be honey
what a weird thing i just did who sniffs
who opens up a
a container of cauliflower and like
gives her a good whiff
five second rule it's funny because as i
do this
it's like i'm expecting this like napalm
bomb to go off in my gut when obviously
that's not how it happens but
i'm just waiting so i was feeling pretty
good having the cauliflower all on its
own
but then as the day went on and i had
some other vegetables and some other
you know foods that maybe had some small
trace amounts of fodmaps in it
and basically what ended up happening
was some fodmap stacking
and i think that is where i run into
issues
so i guess what i've learned from this
is that like
a cauliflower dish on its own is
probably no big deal
but if i'm going to have cauliflower and
a little bit of broccoli
and maybe some green beans and maybe
like a little bit of lettuce
i might feel a little bit bloated and
gassy after that
so all good data and all good
information that i can keep in my back
pocket for future meal plans
alas the show must go on
all right this is what i've learned on
phase two
it seems like the polyols fructans and
galactans
thanks poppy are my biggest triggers and
a lot of the times they're fine in small
amounts or even like
large amounts but it's when i start
getting into
like fodmap stacking throughout the day
so basically like
little bits of like low or moderate
fodmap foods
start to build up as the day goes on
that's when i end up having issues i
also find that i can tolerate those
foods a lot better at like
breakfast or lunch or like earlier on in
the day than i can at dinner time
because dinner time in my house
is witching hour and parents can with
young children can probably
appreciate that eating with toddler
with a toddler and a baby is hella
stressful
so if you find that your ibs is
triggered by stress
i don't know that's a challenging that's
a challenging time to be eating
but i am big on family meals i
totally believe that they're so
important
because of all the research and i really
think that modeling healthy eating
behaviors to my kids
is probably a bigger priority to me than
my digestion
so it's definitely a bit of a give and
take and just something that i have
i'm going to have to balance probably
for the next unforeseeable future with
young children
all right signing out time for phase
three now
finally phase three personalization
so this is basically coming to terms
with a unique understanding
of what i can now tolerate and in what
amount
ideally for most clients with ibs you
should now
no longer need to restrict anything
other than the few foods
in the specific quantities or amounts
that cause you symptoms
so that may mean that i can have a
little bit of broccoli or a little bit
of cauliflower
but probably not an entire whole bowl
full
and ideally also not with other moderate
fodmap foods if we want to kind of avoid
some of those
fodmap stacking effects that we saw so
low fodmap
isn't a diet it's a process that gives
you some insight
to inform your food choices long term
okay
so what does this mean for me like am i
never going to have a dish with
cauliflower or broccoli in it again
no of course i am but just based on some
of the data
that i collected from this experience
you know and knowing that
my symptoms my gas and bloating tend to
be worse at kind of like family meals at
the end of the day
rather than earlier on in the day when i
eat alone i might choose to save that
broccoli or cauliflower for like
a leisurely date night out that is if i
ever get to leave the house
without my children ever again but i
also might choose to like keep tabs on
some of the
smaller fodmap sources that i eat
throughout the day
just based on my experience that i had
with fodmap stacking
and if i want to just kind of forget
about all those learnings and data and
say effort give me a whole
dish of roasted cauliflower then i might
just have to sleep in the guest room
that night
i don't know but as for like the
chickpeas and beans and things like that
that one is the hardest for me to come
to terms with just because
i worked so hard to transition my diet
to more of like a flexitarian style diet
for environmental reasons but ali did
give me a really good tip
she said if i rinse beans really really
well
then i of course cook them then i cool
them and then i rinse them again
that can help to remove some of the
problematic oligosaccharides
that give them their magical status
but yeah basically this is all just data
and i can choose to do what i want with
it when the time comes
i also figure i should chat about
whether or not this experience was
triggering for me
coming from a history of disordered
eating and orthorexia
thankfully i do think that i had
a few things working in my favor that
really helped me
prevent getting into scarcity mentality
so first of all was that i only
eliminated the foods that i
was pretty confident were potential
culprits based on some of the
kind of diet recall and tracking that i
was doing ahead of time
so this allowed me to still have a lot
of my favorite
fun foods like pizza and pasta and
and ice cream and things like that so
that i could still participate in
family meals and have fun and i didn't
feel so
deprived so doing a modified low fodmap
trial like that where you're really only
focusing on removing
some of the major culprits and and the
the most common culprits is definitely
recommended
if you have a history of disordered
eating or disordered eating tendencies
the second thing i did was that i was
really prepared
so doing a lot of meal prep ahead of
time every single week
ensured that the default was that i
always had something
acceptable to eat in the fridge rather
than the default being
that i just wasn't going to eat and
three
was definitely that i had the support of
another dietitian
i cannot stress enough how important it
is
to work through this diet with a
professional with a registered dietitian
because
this is not simple if i needed that
support
and this is my job i definitely
definitely recommend it for
all of you at home who are considering
doing a low fodmap trial
so i hope this gave you a bit of
perspective on what the low fodmap diet
trial process
looks like and also helped to clear up
the misconception that
low fodmap is some kind of weight loss
diet
or even a diet that you stay on for the
rest of your life and on that note
thank you again to foddy foods for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below if
you have any questions about fodmaps or
digestion
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye